think about this simple template where
the amount of work needed to just update
that single message binding in there
right we have to walk through the whole
virtual Dom tree and div dip diff you
just have to recursively keep going down
until somehow you update this in this
process on the other hand if you are
compiling rendering code from a template
usually it can produce far more direct
render instructions with better raw
performance the reason being that the
template is by definition a very very
constraining language for example when
you write code like this we can
instantly tell that there's no way the
order of these P can ever change the
only thing that can change is this
so being static and very restrictive
actually allows the compiler to make
more assumptions about your intention
and that gives it more room to perform
optimizations